hello everybody hope they are good
Bitcoin filled the week at 49k this week
here that we've been talking about for a
week he got 100% filled but not only
that he actually went above it he went
beyond it okay and now we're around
$50,000 Milestone wow of course 50,000
is a psychological level uh it's a round
number but of course 50,000 is more a
psychological level than
49,000 50,000 sounds like you know
sounds quite strong so of course we're
going to see some manipulation in the
chart around this level it always
happens we're going to talk about
something I'm seeing in this area here
with all those weeks but first I want to
take you to the weekly time frame and
see where the next potential starget to
the upsite could be because if we really
look at the left of what has happened
previously there is no much resistance
in this area okay cuz if you notice from
here all the way to 60 65k even there is
not that much resistance okay well 60k
because here in this area there might be
some resistance okay but yeah all the
way from 50,000 to 60,000 there is not
much resistance the only resistance that
I see in the chart is here and that's a
52,000 all right so we could say that if
Bitcoin continues going up and it goes
above 52,1 100 and consolidates above
this Zone then yes we're going to go to
60k very quickly well at least that's
what I see okay then uh at 60k you're
going to see another resistance if you
go above it you know you're want to see
new highs uh but this will be the the
targets that I see to the upside 52,000
next strong resistance and after 52,000
there is really no nothing on the way
all the way to 60k okay that's an $8,000
move that's a huge move we're talking
about around a 15% move maybe let's
check so all the way to 60,000 yeah
that's literally 16% dollar move all
right so uh that would be an interesting
Zone to watch if we continue going up
all right also to the upside to be
honest you got here a couple of
liquidity pools you got yourself one
there and also of
course this one okay so the upsite is
not limited you mean you can still
continue pushing price higher and higher
and higher the only thing is that if we
go into the 4 hours time frame there is
a thing that I don't really like here
all right and you're going to see it
straight
away what happened here at 48,000 and we
talked about this on yesterday's video I
think it was we talk about all these
weeks to the downside but price was not
progressing any further if you notice
what the market maker was doing is a
spike price lower with those weeks and
the market maker was building his lungs
at the lowest area inside this Zone okay
because obviously
why should he um build Longs a
48,500 when he can build Longs a 48,000
or 47,800 so with all these weeks what
is telling you is that the market maker
was building his Longs but now if you
notice we have something similar but in
the opposite side Wicks to the upside
but price not progressing any further
did you guys see that so why is that
telling us M it could be telling us that
the market maker is starting to prepare
some shorts okay of course with those
shorts we don't know if the market maker
is going to aim this this area around
here or this area here or even lower why
not but to me what is telling me here in
the chart is that careful with those
weeks because if we don't break out of
this Zone okay if we don't start
consolidating in this area here then
that is telling me that the market can
make it is going to favor lower prices
very soon and it's going to basically
prepared a long squeeze long squeeze is
going all the market is uh heavily
positioned in Longs which uh I mean if
it's quite easy to understand that with
this parabolic move to the upside and
now also hitting a psychological level
that is 50,000 there is going to be a
lot of retail Traders open in Longs and
those are called late long positions
those are usually the guys that pay the
price okay and that's when usually when
the ret comes so um I cannot be bullish
in in terms of day trading at 50,000
I've been bullish in the last 7 days and
I mean you guys have seen even I was
bullish at 48,000 because I knew when to
go to
49,000 um and we even got higher to
50,000 but at this moment in the chart
that I started to see all these weeks to
the upside price not progressing any
further quite similar to what we saw
here but in the opposite direction
all that the chart is telling me is that
the market maker might be preparing some
shorts okay and this is the 4-Hour time
frame which is quite painful to see this
okay because that's quite powerful
signal so uh I've decided to personally
open a short of 50,000 uh let's see
where that goes of course um I'm I'm I'm
prepared cuz I'm watching the chart I'm
checking the chart all day so if we
start to break around this Zone over
here sorry okay that is what I my threat
will be invalid because we're going to
see if that's the case we're going to
see consolidation before continuation
okay is it still possible that we see a
spike higher above this weeks that will
be a stop hunt in case there are any
Traders preparing shorts like me here
and they are setting their stop losses
Above This resistance okay so yeah there
is still a chance to see a spike above
this area and then a fast um drop below
this Zone that would basically give me
confirmation and I would would add here
to my shorts again at 50,000 but with
more conviction but if in the other hand
we start to see consolidation Above This
level then I get out of my short and I'm
going to favor a a scalp long all the
way to
52,000 okay I hope that was clear guys
now we're going to go to High block
Capital we're want to go to the
liquidation levels because we were
starting to see there that liquidation
Delta was increasing very fast um
providing the idea that a long squeeze
might be in play so I want to check what
those liquidation say today and and try
to make sense of it welcome to hlo
Capital you guys are not familiar with
this uh we're going to check the
liquidation levels straight away let's
see if this loads there it goes let me
change the settings to Max liquidity
remember to take the numbers with a
pinch of so because they are not real
but we can um we can use them as
reference because usually when the
liquidation Delta is between 20 and $30
billion that's usually when we see a
retrace right now we are at $25 billion
of long liquidations cumulative and that
is telling you that the market is
heavily positioned in Long positions and
a long squeeze might be the next move
for the market maker of course am I
completely wrong but that's why we have
invalidations and Targets in the
opposite direction also okay and we know
the triggers of how to switch that
position but right now seeing those
weeks to the upside but price not
progressing any further in the 4 hours
time frame along with the Delta
liquidations $25 billion that's a lot
okay again it's not $25 billion it's a
lot less obviously it's in millions but
um I have experience with this chart and
I use as reference but anybody that has
been using uh the liquidations levels uh
with the max liquidity setting knows
that this is a a lot of liquidity still
okay and that's when a long squeeze
might be in play look at the spikes to
the right a lot of spikes to the
downside
so um careful with that guys okay
because uh if open Twitter I mean you
can just open Twitter and see that
everybody is been eoric at the moment
why well because we've reached 50,000
it's a psychological level this could in
principle be a move to create this
Euphoria in the across Traders and
that's why the heat EXA 50,000 that's
what we're consolidating about 50,000
and then that's when the retrace might
come okay so that's what I'm favoring
that's the artive that I'm favoring
again it doesn't mean if I'm that I'm
right we're going to go to the
liquidation heat map 7 Days time frame
and here you're going to see that there
is a counted argument that is in the 7
Days time frame we can see also some
liquidity at
level so again uh you can use it as a
counter argument or you can use it as
Confluence that if we break or if we get
get acceptance above
50,400 then you have there a very nice
move to the upsite all the way to 517
52,000 all right so I'm not using this
chart to um scare me uh out of that
short but basically to give me
Confluence and conviction that if I
change in in to along if we break above
50,400 then my trade is going to be
right and I'm not going to be wrong
again all right so um it's a thing of
mindset um I don't know how you guys
approach to the Chart when you see uh
counter arguments like this uh I'm sure
that some people would decide to to put
that to put that short
because than Confluence is not with them
but um I go with the chart mainly the
chart is telling me that there is a
sense of a of a retrace I'm going to
take that with obviously Accord the
according risk management but if we get
acceptance about
50,400 that's what I switched into a
long position and I'm sculping this move
all the way to 517 152,000 I hope that
that was clear and I want to take you
back to the Chart because I want to show
you little surprise so regarding trading
setups and technical analysis that's all
that I wanted to say uh I don't have
more analysis for you but I want to show
you a little surprise uh by the way
starting to to drop uh if we if we
continue dropping and we break below
this Zone here then we're going to start
to look for this liquidity pools here um
now you might ask um but how do you know
these are liquidity pools well because
I've been working on an indicator for
many months and the indicator is what I
Mark all the liquidity pools of Interest
like this okay you've seen that it
doesn't take
any time to load it's very fast and it
shows you straight away the liquidity
pulls in the chart also the weeks
earlier it was showing uh this week here
hang on let me
remove let me remove the trading
sessions that's something also that you
can
customize okay so let's see if that goes
there you go and you can see that also
shows the the the weeks okay uh this one
was marking earlier it marks the 50% and
also the 100% of the week that week just
go failed also we had another one here e
go failed buy another week now that week
it doesn't need to get filled because
it's filling a previous week to be
honest uh so this is the type of things
that I'm going to try to to change in
the indicator because this week
shouldn't be uh showing still we pretty
much filled the 50% of the week uh only
by $10 uh by the way look at that
Bitcoin starting to Dr up
heavily uh so uh that's very good
because because uh that means I'm making
money but um my point is that we drop
now below this level that we are right
now then we're going to start to enter
this liquidity pool over here and once
we enter the liquidity pool we should
continue retracing it okay and of course
if you H jump again into this liquidity
pool over here you're going to continue
retracing it so this that's the
basically the thing that is going to uh
help me to decide what I'm taking
profits you also have here the 1 or 50a
by the way the indicator includes the 1
hour 50a by the way look at that it's
starting to
retrace wow look at that
candle wow all right um careful with the
1 hour 50 me because that's the level
that we could see some support but
insane guys I mean I'm sad because I was
basically finishing the video and I was
going to plad it but at least you can
see how it's playing out what we've been
saying okay go to the for time frame
you're going to I see this more clear
let me remove this indicator okay uh
weeks to the upset price not progressing
any further means that the market maker
was building shorts okay go to the 1
hour time frame you can start to see
that playing out in the chart now of
course you have to see how it plays out
this 1 hour 15 May we've already started
to retrace this liquidity pool uh the
liquidity pool will be should get
updated once this uh candle closes boom
uh that's basically showing you that the
the indicator is is working well that's
what I want to show you and I just
posted on telegram uh and the telegram
channel is Free by the way you can join
a whole post about how um we've been
working uh in this indicator it's been
basically trial and error because nobody
there is no indicator anywhere that
marks you the weeks or the liquidity
pools that's something uh that we've
made up so uh it was very difficult to
to code um so far what we have still in
its own work we're going to open the
beta very soon probably in March that
beta test will probably last a few
months until the indicator is 100% ready
and you guys are going to be able to
join the beta test we'll create a
separate telegram uh chat dedicated only
for this to give ideas feedback about
indicator to make it better to make it
stronger and only students from the
course because those are familiar with
the trading system system will get
access to the beta to the indicator is
going to be an invite only indicator as
in the beta and also uh of course
anybody any active Traders using my
referral link because that's a fantastic
way to support uh my content so uh
that's basically everything I want to
tell you regarding Bitcoin let's see how
it starts to play out I would like to
see this scandle closing below this low
so I still has 20 minutes let's see how
it closes that way it will be telling me
that the next
um support potential support will be the
50 may you break it and we're going to
start retracing even this liquidity pool
to the downside now if that's not the
case and we don't close the Candlestick
below this low here or the 50 ma access
support then we're going to see some
more consolidation here when the market
maker could continue building shorts
until we see the opposite that would be
acceptance of 50,400 and that would push
price to 52k so I hope that was clear
guys thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you soon